if you were to Define what it meant to
be a banana you had to tick every box on
that list and then you could be nothing
but a banana we're going to look at a
sequence and show that it converges to a
limit you weren't expecting
so the sequence is as follows the first
term is nine second term is 99 third
term 999. fourth term you guessed it
four nines and we're going to continue
with this pattern so obviously the
sequence goes to Infinity we're adding
more and more nines so in the usual
sense this is a Divergent sequence it
goes to Infinity it's getting bigger but
I'm going to show you that in fact
this tends to minus one this sequence of
adding more and more nines making the
number larger and larger in a certain
situation can be shown to tend to minus
one and here's how it works first of all
we need to establish what we mean by
saying a sequence tends to a particular
number this might seem like something
you know or you've seen before but this
is going to be really important in
justifying why this is minus one so bear
with me so if we start with a different
sequence so suppose I have three over
two four thirds five over four six over
five and it's going to continue so we're
adding one to each of the numerators
numbers on top we're adding one to each
number on the bottom so the nth term if
we would sort of go along and say pick a
certain point in the sequence what does
the nth term look like at that position
it's going to be n plus two over n plus
one so first term plug it in we get
three on the top over two third turn
here this would be n equals three we get
five on top four on the bottom whatever
position down you might say to me
finally the 1000th term in the sequence
it's a thousand and two over a thousand
one now this hopefully you can see is
going to ten to one as we increase n we
go further and further along the
sequence the top and the bottom get
closer and closer together so we can get
as close to one as we want by going
further and further down the sequence
so the way we would show that is you
take your nth term which here is M plus
two over M plus one and we subtract off
what we think the limit is so here we
think it's going to be one and then we
work out the distance between these two
so I'm calling this our distance
function now if we're working in the
real numbers which these are all real
numbers then the distance function is
just the modulus of one number subtract
the other so we take the modulus because
it's a distance so it should be positive
you can't really have a negative
distance so here the distance in the
real numbers is n plus two over n plus
one minus one what is n plus two over n
plus one well we can simplify that and
say well that's actually the same as n
plus one plus another one all over n
plus one minus one but then we've got an
N plus one over an N plus one so that's
a one so we can say that's actually one
plus one over n plus one minus one so we
get one over
and plus one
so again with this distance function the
usual way of measuring distance we can
show that the nth term of the sequence
and what we think the limit is we can
say the distance between them looks like
one over n plus one so as we now go
further and further down the sequence
what we're doing is we're letting n tend
to Infinity we're making n bigger and
bigger what happens to our distance as n
gets bigger the distance tends to zero
so as n tends to Infinity the distance
between the two things is 1 over n plus
one which very clearly tends to zero so
we would say this sequence converges to
one and we've done that using the
distance function which for the real
numbers is just modulus of one of them
minus the other
I'm going to need more paper do as
always the reason I've introduced the
distance function as some of you may
have guessed is if we're going to show
our sequence of nines is tending to
minus one we obviously can't use the
normal definition of distance because
the distance between a larger larger
number and minus one is getting bigger
so it's it's just not going to work it's
not going to tend to zero so we need to
think about what other definition of
distance can we use to show that this
sequence is indeed going to minus one
and the one we use is called the two
attic metric
and we will check this is a distance you
say the distance between two numbers X
and Y so X and Y are going to be
integers because here in our sequence
we're only working with integers so
we'll keep things simple so the distance
between two integers in this metric is
defined to be 1 divided by 2 to the m
where m is the largest power of two that
divides x minus y so this feels a little
complicated so let's look at an example
let's think about what does this mean
let's suppose X is 100 and Y is 4. so in
the usual measure of distance we would
say the modulus of x minus y is the
modulus of 100 minus four then 96 apart
feels hopefully kind of obvious
now in the two attic metric we've
changed our definition of distance
so we need to think about what power of
2 divides their difference so we already
know the difference the difference
between them is 96. so if we think of
powers of two we've got 2 4 8 16 32 64.
128 is obviously too big so I'm going to
stop there 64 well that's 2 to the 6 but
64 doesn't divide 96 it's smaller than
it but 64 times 2 which would be the
next smallest thing you could have
wouldn't give you 96. so we actually
need to go down to two to the 5 which is
32 which perfectly divides 96. so 2 to
the 5 is 32 32 times 3 gives us 96. 2 to
the 5 divides the difference between our
numbers so so in our definition we can
say in the two attic metric the distance
between 100 and 4 is 1 over 2 to the
biggest power so here two to the five so
that's going to be 1 over 32. so usual
definition of distance that we're all
used to these numbers are 96 apart 104.
however in this metric they are 1 over
32. apart
which doesn't feel at all natural and or
useful or useful I mean well that's a
whole other conversation we're entering
the realm of pure maths this now that
you set me off on this it is useful
because we learn properties about the
numbers
so this kind of Investigation okay
this isn't a distance in our world but
we can learn things about distributions
of numbers through this so this two
addict metric can be generalized and is
used to actually in fields medal level
research to learn about rational numbers
so beyond beyond my pay grade beyond my
ability to do the maths but there is
some usefulness in there
so we've got our two attic metric so
I've just told you this is a way of
figuring out how far apart two numbers
are but
you need to check from a mathematical
perspective that it does everything you
would expect a distance measure to do so
we have a set of axioms in order to be a
distance function it maps from two
numbers in our starting space into the
real numbers we get an answer that's a
real number where D satisfies three
things this one's called positivity and
these should hopefully fit with your
intuition of what we might expect from a
distance if we have two numbers X and Y
the distance between them is greater
than or equal to zero we're talking
about distances okay they might not fit
our usual way we think about them but
they still need to be positive you can't
have a non
non-positive distance negative distance
makes no sense and in fact you can say
and it equals zero if and only if x is
equal to Y so you only have a zero
distance if it's the same Point again
hopefully fits with our usual notion
second one is called symmetry so this
says the distance between X and Y so if
I start with X and move to a point Y I
should obviously get the same thing if I
start at Y and move back to x d of X Y
is D of y x quite straightforwards
doesn't matter where we start the third
one is called the triangle law now this
one best seen by picture if I start at
point x and I want to go to point Z then
what this says is moving directly from X
to Z is always going to be faster than
going via some third Point why again
fits our usual way of thinking about
distances if you're thinking about the
usual measure of distance this is saying
the shortest
way to move between two points in the
plane is a straight line of course it
changes if you're on spheres and
changing your geometry in terms of our
function that says the distance between
x and z
has to be less than or equal to so it's
shorter than going by a detour so if we
did dxy plus d y z it's not
algebraically so these three axioms
three rules need to be satisfied in
order for a function D to be called a
distance in terms of the mathematical
definition of a distance so we just need
to check that our two addict metric
satisfies these three things because at
this point you're just taking my word
that this is a reasonable thing to do
even though we get a rather ridiculous
answer so we do want to verify this
let's write down our definition one over
two to the m where the M was the largest
power of two that divides their
difference so is this positive it's one
over a power of two it's certainly a
positive number so we can say that works
we're all good symmetry if I do the
distance between X and Y is that the
same as doing Y and X well here we were
finding the largest power of two that
divided x minus y so what that means is
we're saying 2 to the m divides x minus
y so if we write that out algebraically
what that tells you is that x minus y
equals something let's call it a times 2
to the m because if this is going to be
a factor of that there has to be
something else so in our previous
example we had this was 96 we had 32
here so a would be 3. it's just that
other integer part of our division so if
2 to the m divides that it means that so
if I now say well what's y minus X well
that's just minus a times 2 to the m so
the same power of 2 still divides the
number the other way around we just got
a minus sign in front we don't care
about that we're in the integers so
we're allowed negative numbers so so
positivity could go at the window there
positivity does still hold because the
function itself was the biggest power of
2 that divides the number so even though
there's a minus here
this so this might be minus 96. the
biggest power of 2 is 32 so it's still
the biggest power of 2 multiplied by
some integer now it's a negative one
but the power of 2 is still positive so
we're okay so that gives us symmetry now
triangle law a little bit of work
required let's start by thinking about X
Y I suppose this is 1 over 2 to the m
and let's suppose the same power also
divides this one one over two to the m
as well so we're sort of thinking here
what is the largest power of 2 that
divides both of these two okay and pick
that one to be our distance for these
two because what we can then say is this
means x minus y is equal to uh some
number let's call it a times two to the
m this one means y minus Z is some
number B times 2 to the m these of
course could have powers of 2 in them
there could be a bigger power of two
that divides this one but we want a
power of two that works on both of them
and then if we try and work out this one
so for here we have to consider x minus
Z so what's x minus Z we've got
equations for things here so we can say
x minus Z is X is going to be y Plus A2
to the m and then we want to subtract up
Z but Z if I take it over there and do
that Z is y minus B2 to the m so x minus
Z we're going to lose the Y's and we've
got minus minus becomes a plus so what
we've got is a plus b times 2 to the m
so what this is saying is if I have a
power of 2 that divides x minus y and a
power the same power of 2 that also
divides Y and Z then it definitely
divides x minus Z and it can't get
smaller if you sort of look at what's
happening here because it divides these
two by this algebra it's definitely a
factor of this one so it definitely
divides that one but it can get bigger
the power of two here could get bigger
because a plus b as I mentioned here
these could have factors of two it so
when you add them together this could
contain additional powers of two but
that would just mean this one had a
larger power of two what's our
definition of distance it's one over
that power so you could potentially have
a bigger power of two dividing x minus Z
but that means the distance between x
and z is smaller which is what we needed
so that one's a little bit harder to get
your head around like and I recommend
working through this for yourselves
actually because this is the kind of
Crux of showing that this metric works
but it will satisfy the triangle law and
therefore
as ridiculous as it may sound the two
attic metric is a distance function just
because it matches those things I mean
if I if I said to you all bananas are
yellow and then I pulled out a yellow
Volkswagen and I said look that's yellow
so that must be a banana as well just
because it happens to meet the criteria
it doesn't feel like to me it has to
still be a distance
you're telling me it does it's I I see
your point but I think
if you were to Define what it meant to
be a banana it would be it is yellow it
is a fruit it has the curve whatever it
was there would be several things and so
you would create almost like an
exhaustive list such that absolutely
everything you had to tick every box on
that list and then you could be nothing
but a banana you haven't convinced me
though that this three is exhausted yeah
well that's a fair point so yeah I mean
this is why they're called axioms and
this is why this is the mathematical
definition of a distance for this video
I'll take your word for it that that
list is exhaustive yes that this
anything satisfying these three things
from the mathematical perspective we
call a distance now our real world
definition of distance fits these
okay when we talk about the numbers and
taking the modulus it's obviously
positive Symmetry and it does satisfy
the triangle off with the picture so the
one we're used to in the real numbers
is a distance of course that doesn't in
any way prove that all distances have to
look like this but the one we used to
fits these rules and it just so happens
that we can find other distances some of
them are sensible like
um great circles great arcs on a sphere
they will also satisfy the same kind of
thing but it just so happens that here
it it fits the axioms we as
mathematicians have said if it fits the
axioms it's a distance so we can now use
it to measure distance for this
particular sequence all right I'll let
you do it
we showed at the beginning that if this
is going to converge to some limit which
I'm telling you is -1 then what we need
to show is that the distance between the
nth term which we'll work out in just a
moment of the sequence and what we think
the limit is which here is -1 we need
the distance of those two to ten to zero
as n goes to Infinity so we did the
example with M plus 2 over n plus 1 and
we showed that that does indeed 10 to 1
because we got 1 over n plus one here so
as we make n bigger and bigger and
bigger one over a bigger number we get
zero so the nth term well if this is the
first term it's 10 minus one this is the
second term so let's write that 10 minus
one this is 10 squared minus 1. 10 cubed
minus one so it's actually a nice and
easy 10 to the N minus one is our nth
term so we need to show this and that
tells us that this sequence does indeed
go to minus one what's our definition of
distance we're using the two addict
metric because if we use the real
numbers it obviously is infinity that's
no fun we want it to get minus one so we
need to find the largest power of two
which divides that number minus that
number
so of course minus one plus one ten to
the N so what's the largest power of two
which divides ten to the N well 10 to
the N is 2 to the m times 5 to the N
because ten is two times five two to the
N is a factor so our distance in the two
addict metric between the nth term of
the sequence the limit minus one is one
divided by two to the N what happens to
this is n tends to Infinity 1 over a
bigger and bigger and bigger number this
tends to zero as n tends to Infinity so
what this means is n tends to Infinity
is saying as the number in the sequence
10 to the N minus 1. as this number gets
bigger and bigger and bigger more and
more Nines in a row the distance between
this really big number and minus one
gets smaller and smaller because in this
measure of distance the two attic space
in this space the way that we measure
the distance is one over the biggest
power of two that divides it so this
number is getting huge and it's getting
closer and closer to minus one in this
space so we can say the sequence of
nines converges to minus one does this
happen with a lot of other sequences
like is this is this some unique
property of numbers with lots of Nines
in it and the minus one or could you
pull could you manufacture other
sequences where this happens you can do
this with any sequence you want so the
nines I just picked because it works
quite nicely with the algebra
the other thing you can change is here
we've done on a two attic metric the
more General case is p addict where p is
a prime
so you need a prime number
for
lots of reasons but that again is I'm
going to say a little bit beyond what
I'm trying to get across here in this
particular case but as long as you pick
any prime number you can measure
distance in the same way so you for the
three addict you would say it's the
biggest power of three that divides
the difference between these two numbers
and then your distance is one over three
to that power similar kind of idea so if
you've done eight 88 888 and used eights
instead of nines would this necessarily
still work does it depend on the numbers
no that would work I think that off the
top of my head I want to say that would
be zero because Eight's perfectly
divisible by two if you change the
numbers in your sequence the limit will
change so minus one here isn't special
that is just the limit for the sequence
with all the nines if you had sequence
with all the eights like you said you're
going to get a different limit
and it might not even converge
it doesn't have to converge to something
like because I could write down an
arbitrary sequence that's not going to
necessarily converge so you do have to
be careful it needs to be
something which
almost has been like artificially
constructed to make sure it's going to
converge and then you need to figure out
what that limit is and finding that
limit can be quite tricky
so I told you it was minus one but to
actually work out why it's minus one a
little bit of work involved in that so
possibly right now we could put on the
screen a few examples of other sequences
and what they converge to we could
our thanks to Jane Street for supporting
this video now you might be wondering
why is like a high-flying research
driven trading firm supporting a number
file video basically it's because they
think the people watching people like
you are the sort of smart curious
problem-solving types and maybe some of
you could be the next person to join
their teams in the likes of New York
London or here in Hong Kong
not sure how much work I'd get done here
actually but anyway there are
interesting jobs internships free
programs you can join all sorts of stuff
going on go to janestreak.com and click
here on join Jane Street to find out
more this is a company that really wants
the best people and it wants to look
after them to make sure their careers
are interesting fun successful and you
could be one of them so go to
janestreet.com check out the website all
your questions are answered there and
our thanks to them for supporting this
video
foreign
puzzle I'm going to write down the list
of numbers 1 through 16 in the order
that they appear in the tray so for
example